we are located in the NASA Ames Research
Park here at NASA Ames Research Center
we were the first university to be
located here I think NASA saw the the
ties especially in robotics and in
software engineering Silicon Valley has
a long tradition of private companies
working with academia to develop and
innovate on new ideas for Carnegie
Mellon to be part of this mixes just
provides another great resource for
companies like Nokia it's really
important for our students and for
companies here to have connections
through fellowships scholarships
practicum support research grants and
faculty grabs for multiple reasons one
of course is it supports the work to it
enables students to come to the work and
three it enables us to understand what
companies really want I think it's very
very important for the PhD students
today to actually have this close
collaboration with the industry because
I've been there myself and it's so easy
that we forget that there is a real
world out there that you need to solve
real problems one of the most
interesting collaborations that I've
been able to start this with Ericsson
I've been able to work with some of the
team members who are working on
something similar to what I'm doing and
we meet every other week and we get to
discuss ideas it's a good opportunity
for me because I can bring what I learn
on campus and work with a group a group
of excellent people in nokia we have
that good connection with industry that
were very important to the engineering
student the students here are are able
and in fact encouraged to actually
approach different faculty to talk about
their own research and getting the idea
from you know tons of expert in all type
of field my research mostly focuses on
having the sensors having devices
understand things sense things on a more
human level this is one of the project
that we're working on
it's a sensor fly project now the idea
here is that in emergency situation
people error could be trapped in a
building like earthquakes or during a
fire why don't we just send a whole
bunch of these cheap helicopters inside
the building to look for people we don't
have to needlessly put people in harm's
way one of the programs we're starting
here which I'm helping to form is this
disaster management initiative DMI we
call it it's basically to provide open
technology solutions to
multi-jurisdictional all hazard kind of
disasters and we hope we can reduce
response time increase the effectiveness
to get people both to able to plan
prepare better for disasters as well as
to respond and to recover from disasters
so carnegie mellon center sits in the
middle of this little ecosystem where we
can be an experimental test bed so for
several years within our research lab
we've worked on technologies that allow
for people who speak different languages
to communicate with each other across
the language barrier our latest venture
there is called gb go it's a a
smartphone app that runs on an iPhone
and allows for people to communicate if
they don't speak each other's language
so it's all on the device runs
completely offline the companies in the
valley that do wireless and mobile
devices see a real benefit for the
research and the students that we that
we graduate to work in these areas
companies like Ericsson Nokia Samsung
they they need this technology the
universities do research that Ericsson
doesn't do so it's very natural for us
to if we want to look at long-term
trends and long-term research we want to
go to the university's we have been
partnering with Samsung they approached
us too because they were familiar with
the quality of our research we are
willing to work with the client very
closely to find the best match between
the research that we conduct and
business needs Carnegie Mellon Silicon
Valley is it is a fantastic institution
it is a fantastic place to do
cutting-edge research to work with
entrepreneurs to work with other
companies and just to have that that
cross-fertilization of ideas it's a
fantastic place that's why I came here
to be able to do research and to be
entrepreneurial and to educate the next
generation of students
you